[Music]
I want to keep Miri.
Don't be stupid. What can you do? I
could
n't do anything. I didn't even try. I look at the reality that I
ran away from my father and was just a breathing doll.
That was fine, but now
I know that
people's hands are warm.
[Music] Don't
worry about having a comfortable place. What
will become of you if you leave Miri alone?
Are we going to take away Miri's parents and forget her without making any amends?  Ha, if you
look at it any further, you
shouldn't get involved. We have to protect it, right? Think about it.
What can we do for Miri? You
're better at thinking, Kazuki. Change. We'll make Miri happy this time.
Do it,
Kazuki, I'm sure you can make that child happy too
[Music]